hi I'm James Corden I'm about to move to
America and GQ are giving me a crash
course in American isms
bought the farm I think it's real and I
think it means that you've it's that the
done the whole thing he's bought the lot
oh he bought the farm get your dander up
is real and it means to get your freak
on same thing sex very much for me is
connected to being agitated and angry
and but and then and then tears and then
disappointment that's mostly how it goes
that's false but what does it mean
that's like posh you know we're posh
comes from right port out starboard home
so when you would go on a cruise ship
the richest people the best view would
be portside out starboard home so they
would put in their luggage posh so
that's where that comes from I think
it's real I think it means don't throw
in the towel Oh sounds real better than
high on the hog Jesus trying to see how
you'd say it do Janaka we will have the
last night why I bounced the mounts dude
no way bro you ever happen to Jake you
bounce the mouse what no I don't think
it's real
horse of a different color I think it's
real I don't think anyone would come up
with that
if someone's from a good family stock
like if you're a Clinton poke the donkey
is real and it's if you have slept with
a reality TV show star someone from the
e-channel
someone who makes like her my home with
my family if you slept with some one of
them you've poked the donkey so that
what it means I think is real what well
that just sounds like masturbation
doesn't it I mean that's what that is if
it doesn't exist if this isn't the thing
I say we make it a thing right now if
you're watching I say this is a hashtag
right now I'm off for two minutes to
polish the cream so there you go I feel
almost American now I certainly look
like most Americans but none who have
ever been on this GQ video thing just
probably mostly so
I mean I like I'm not saying that in a
bad way
I like Zac Efron great I wish you'd get
back on the drugs